[Music]
almost half of land in the European
Union is used for farming the EU wants
to protect and promote its agricultural
sector with reform of the Common
Agricultural Policy after 2020 in the
pipeline Parliament is pushing for more
flexibility and fairer funding the aim
is to make farming fairer across the
whole of the block rural regions would
get more funding and members want more
support for young and new farmers we
have to reflect that the income in
different regions in Europe is different
it wouldn't be fair I think to bring the
all the farmers in Europe do the same to
the same income members want to keep EU
farming competitive so they are pushing
for the cap to be sufficiently financed
the question is which kind of farming do
we want in Europe I personally think we
should have in Europe farms which family
based which are sustainable which are
innovative and which are attractive for
young people MEP is watched the future
cap to make farms more environmentally
sustainable as well as to foster
innovation and smart farming practices
so that the EU has food security and a
flourishing farm sector for the years to
come
[Music]
you